Hello, science fans.
Picking your favourite
chromosome is a little bit
like picking your
favourite child.
Everyone has one, but no one
really admits to it.
If I had to pick a favourite
chromosome, it would not be
chromosome 18.
At 76 million base pairs it's
one of the more stunted,
shrivelled chromosomes
in the human genome.
And it only harbours around 350
genes, making 18 the least
dense for genes on chromosomes
in our genome.
So of those 76 million base
pairs, almost none of it is
encoding actual genes, and
that's the same across the
whole human genome.
Imagine that these lovely fairy
lights were the whole
human genome.
Well, the coding sections only
account for less than 3%,
rather like this.
So what is the rest of
it actually doing?
Well, lots of it are genetic
control panel switches that
turn genes on and off, because
they have to come on and off
at exactly the right time.
But large parts of the genome
appear to be doing nothing
whatsoever.
We used to call it junk DNA--
the hangover of four billion
years worth of evolution.
But there is a difference
between junk, the stuff that
we keep in the attic that might
have a function, and
rubbish, the stuff that
we throw away.
And recently we've been
discovering that lots of junk
might be doing something
after all, although
we're not sure what.
And that's the reason that we
have to keep on sequencing
more and more people's genomes,
including crappy, old
chromosome 18.
Because I think we're going to
find out that some of that
junk might be rather useful.
That's science, folks.
Happy Christmas.